thank you very much and I got some
breaking news and it is about Harry and
Megan and a statement from Prince Harry
and Megan saying they're stepping back
from royal duties and the statement says
after many months of reflection and
internal discussions we have chosen to
make a transition this year in starting
to carve out a progressive new role
within this institution we intend to
step back as senior members of the royal
family and work to become financially
independent while continuing to fully
support her Majesty the Queen that the
statement goes on it is with your
encouragement particularly over the last
few years that we feel prepared to make
this adjustment we now plan to balance
our time between the United Kingdom and
North America continuing to honor our
duty to the Queen the Commonwealth and
those institutions we are patrons of
this geographic balance it says will
enable us to raise our son with an
appreciation for the royal tradition
into which he was born while also
providing our family with the space to
focus on the next chapter including the
launch of our new charitable entity we
look forward the statement says to
sharing the full details of the exciting
next step in due course as we continue
to collaborate with her Majesty the
Queen the Prince of Wales the Duke of
Cambridge and all relevant parties until
then please accept our deepest thanks
for your continued support that
statement just in from Prince Harry and
Megan Markel and perhaps not such a
surprise given they've just spent six
weeks I think it was in Canada and a six
week break in Canada and they have been
talking recently of maybe starting a new
life in North America but now it seems
they've been conversations with the
Queen conversations with his
follow the Prince of Wales and it seems
that there is now a decision that after
many months of reflection they are
choosing to make this transition to step
back from the royal family certainly to
step back as senior members of the royal
family and to work on becoming what they
say is financially independent while
continuing to fully support her Majesty
the Queen which raises the issue of
whether Megan Markel who had a career of
course in television would even consider
going back to work they're talking about
becoming financially independent and
they say that over the last few years
they have felt that we feel prepared to
make this adjustment and they're now
talking about this balance of their time
between the United Kingdom and North
America but they point out to continue
to honor their duty to the Queen at the
Commonwealth and their patronage is now
it's interesting what impact or what
effect or what influence megan Markel
had on this given that she has been
speaking recently in a television
documentary about the pressure that she
feels under and hinting that it was
pressure from the media and she found it
life very difficult and the the
documentary on television made it pretty
clear that she felt life was quite
difficult in the spotlight and Prince
Harry was speaking on that documentary
too of his agreement so